hi
quickly before miss coffee bean comes if
you already watched our video about the
char former go away there's nothing you
can see here
okay
here she comes
hi what is tokenization you know that
line of code you use from hugging phase
transformers and never care about in
today's video we will see how this works
tokenization is that part in
pre-processing that is done to text
before throwing it into your favorite
language model say bird it is a
pre-processing step so it is independent
of the later training process but it's
crucial for most transformers without
organization each word of the english
vocabulary would have to be assigned a
unique vector on the input side and when
predicting the masked word in the output
the choice would have to consider the
whole vocabulary
and if you believe that the english
vocabulary that one can find in a
dictionary is already huge think about
how it can grow even faster with all
words that are not in a dictionary like
compound words created on the fly by
someone as a stylistic figure
or all possible typos right a mistyped
word is also a word and should have a
way to be processed by a language model
this is where tokenization comes in to
at least partially solve this problem by
creating a smaller vocabulary of word
building blocks this hopes to cover as
much of the dictionary as possible
including unexpected words therefore
tokenizers first segment the sentence
into words harder for some languages
than for others i'm looking at you
chinese thai in korean because you do
not have white space separation then the
words are parsed into sub words so that
even though supposedly the dictionary
does not have the word pre-processing in
it and therefore no vector
representation to associate with it the
tokenizer can divide the word into pre
and processing supposing that pre and
processing are already in the vocabulary
and have a vector association and this
works great in very regular kinds of
words that can be decomposed into known
blocks but does not solve the problem of
noisy text full of typos where the
possibilities of mistyping are so many
that a fallback to a known sub-word is
either impossible or leads to
misunderstandings so tokenization being
so rigid can become a problem an even
bigger one when working with multiple
languages where the auto vocabulary
problem becomes even greater with every
additional language the model has to
handle even more the downside of
tokenization is that on downstream
applications you are kind of forced to
use the same tokenizer as the model was
trained with because the trained model
is very much dependent on the
tokenization it is used to even though
your task might benefit from other
tokenizations you now must stick with
the initial ones no you're not allowed
to see other tokenizers miss coffee bean
well we hope that we could make the
purpose and inner workings of
tokenization now clearer to you do not
forget to like and subscribe
okay bye
hey so it's me again as you have perhaps
already noticed this is a partial
re-upload of the explanation of
tokenization we did already in the chart
former video we think we did quite an
okay job at explaining it there very
general but that general explanation is
not search engine retrievable if you
search just by tokenization so through
this video we just wanted to resurface
that explanation a little bit
and that was it
okay how does miss coffee bean usually
in these videos
okay bye
[Music]